retour en salles de rédaction pour la
suite du 19/20 les larmes du bonheur
tout à l'heure à orly 64 enfants
roumains vont enfin pouvoir vivre dans
leur famille française d'adoption grâce
présidentielle pour iphone que 43 ans il
avait été condamné à 20 ans de réclusion
criminelle en 83
il a été libéré ce matin de la prison de
loos et bild ouf philippe poupon est
arrivé à bon port huit jours après son
naufrage nous l'attendions au cap en
afrique du sud
catastrophe écologique pour la gironde
200 mille hectares de pins menacés dans
la forêt des landes après l'invasion de
chenilles processionnaires attendu
pendant trois ans les enfants de
roumanie sont enfin arrivés tout à
l'heure à orly 63 enfants bientôt 64 qui
signifie mieux que tous que la roumanie
vient de changer radicalement de régime
nous allons dans un instant rejoindre
orly mais tout de suite ces images
qu'une famille a ramené tout à l'heure
de bucarest
les familles étaient seuls accepté à
bord de l'avion spécial affrété par le
gouvernement français pour aller à
bucarest ce midi rencontrer les 64
enfants et les ramener ce soir à paris
voici donc des images tournées par
monsieur chabin l'un des pères de
famille dans adoptive
ce soir ils sont ensemble dans leur
famille et voici les premiers instants
donc des retrouvailles et les manières
relance les premiers retrouvailles avec
leurs parents la fin d'un cauchemar
je vous rappelle que deux paradoxal et
c'est la grève de la faim pour arriver à
ce résultat ce soir
voilà donc des images qui ont été
enregistrées par une famille ce midi à
bucarest maintenant comment les choses
se sont elles passées à 17h54 quand
l'avion spécial s'est posé à orly
et bien ce carreau in fine ce qui nous
raconte ces moments de grande émotion
dans une cohue indescriptible 64 enfants
roma débarque avec un de leurs parents
adoptifs
un seul membre par famille a eu le droit
de faire ce voyage à bucarest
les enfants ont entre 2 et 9 ans il ne
parle pas français
et ce premier contact avec leur nouveau
pays en à folles plus d'un l'émotion est
grande la plupart des familles adoptives
n'ont pas vu leurs enfants depuis trois
ou quatre ans
car en 87 chercher secours refuser toute
sortie d'enfants roumat légalement
adopter par d
français certaines familles ne pouvait
même plus faire le voyage vers bucarest
aujourd'hui c'est la fin d'un cauchemar
mais il reste encore une vingtaine
d'enfants roumanie qui n'ont pu venir à
cause de problèmes administratifs
mais ceci devrait rapidement pouvoir
rejoindre leurs familles d'adoption
c'était donc il y à une heure et demie
environ à orly l'arrivée de ses enfants
de roumanie nous retournons en direct à
orly rejoindre jean jacques bazié
jean-jacques vous êtes aux côtés de
madame hélène dorlhac secrétaire d'état
chargée de la famille
oui tout à fait les nerd or là que
secrétaire d'état chargée de la famille
le fait que ce soit vous au nom du
gouvernement qui soyez venu venus
accueillir au cc famille à orly est ce
que c'est un symbole plutôt que ce soit
le mini des affaires étrangères je crois
que c'est un symbole et il est bien
entendu que c'est le ministre des
affaires étrangères qui a mené toute la
négociation tant que les enfants étaient
en roumanie mais à partir du moment où
ils sont sur le sol français c'est tout
à fait normal me semble-t-il que ce soit
le secrétaire d'état chargé de la
famille qui viennent les accueillir et
pouvoir ainsi m'associer à la joie et à
l'émotion qui était très grande ce soir
pour accueillir ces enfants
la question qui se pose bien sûr
maintenant c'est 19 enfants qui restent
en roumanie et fiona pour encore
longtemps
oui je crois qu'il faut dire d'abord que
dire la joie une importance que plus de
60 enfants soit arrivé ce soir ceux ci
n'étaient pas encore à espérer il ya
quinze jours
donc voyez et je crois qu'il faut dès ce
soir rendre un premier hommage au
nouveau gouvernement roumain qui a
trouvé une solution rapide à ces
problèmes et qui a fait de ce problème
humain une action prioritaire dont
d'abord remerciant le gouvernement
roumain et d'autre part bien sûr il ya
les enfants qui ne sont pas rentrés ils
ne sont pas rentrés
je pense pour des questions
administratives qui vont être je
l'espère dans les plus brefs délais en
cours de règlement
mais je voudrais aussi ce soir rappelé
l'action est tout à fait importante à la
fois du ministère des affaires
étrangères au cours de ces deux années
avec des négociations très difficiles à
l'époque où le le tyran empêcher la
sortie d'enfants qui pourtant avait été
légalement adopter et l'action récent de
madame georgina dufoix qui à la demande
expresse du président de la république
est intervenu directement roumanie
auprès des plus hautes autorités de
l'état et a eu satisfaction donc d'abord
c'est la joie pensant aux autres enfants
qui sont restés espérons que le problème
sera réglé
agréablement
o qui viennent donc ce sont bien des
problèmes administratifs qui gêne pour
l'instant pour l'instant d'après ce que
je sais ce sont essentiellement des
problèmes administratifs
merci madame de relaxe oui et puis
madame dort là que je pense que vous
êtes en mesure de nous entendre et ce
qu'il faut préciser en conclusion c'est
que tout est en train de changer d'un
point de vue législatif en roumanie et
que les motif d'abandon d'enfants sont
peut-être en passe de disparaître et que
les jeunes mères de famille qui a
abandonné leurs enfants roumanie ne le
font plus ça c'est un problème qui
effectivement se pose tout électeur qui
a les problèmes d'adoption d'enfants
étrangers
c'est certain qu'il ya certainement des
enfants qui sont abandonnées parce qu'il
ya des mauvaises conditions de vie pour
leurs familles
lorsque ces conditions de vie
s'améliorent bien entendu les familles
naturelles peuvent peut-être espérer
pouvoir élever le remplacer c'est le
voeu que nous leur fournirons mais là
aussi ces deux cas par cas je crois
qu'il faut savoir respecter à la fois le
choix les familles naturelles et pour
les enfants qui sont adoptées je me dis
bien en toute légalité
c'est à dire pour lesquelles les
familles naturelles ont consenti à
l'adoption
eh bien il faut une famille adoptante
que leur front enfin l'amour auquel ils
ont droit
merci madame et c'est le cas ce soir
donc dans 64 familles françaises alors
sur place en roumanie les nouvelles
autorités affrontent deux difficultés le
voisinage disons encombrants de l'urss
et l'impatience bien compréhensible de
la population roumaine et sur ces deux
plans laurence les enseignements sont
nombreux ce soir les étudiants les
partis d'opposition conteste la
légitimité de certains membres du front
de salut national ils contestent aussi
la date des prochaines élections du mois
d'avril
sur ce dernier point d'ailleurs le
gouvernement semble être prêt à céder
jean-paul chéroy la roumanie nouvelle
vie à 100 à l'heure activité
diplomatique réforme et première
manifestation d'opposition s'y succèdent
à un train d'enfer rapide comme la
visite d' edouard chevardnadzé ce matin
le ministre des affaires étrangères
soviétique s'est entretenu avec jeune
fille j'ai ce coup selon le nouveau
numéro un roumain
le changement de régime ne pose aucun
problème quant aux intérêts réciproques
des deux pays pourtant les deux hommes
ont dû aborder au moins un sujet
problématique la moldavie cette
république soviétique
été annexé en 1944 65% de la population
y parle pense et se revendique room
passe on voit de plus en plus forte aux
réclamants une réunification chavernac
des éviers secours ont évoqué une
ouverture des frontières mais sans
qu'elle soit remise en cause
sur le plan intérieur il y est ce qu
affronte une fronde estudiantine et
politique les partis d'opposition
récemment créé demande un report des
élections prévues en avril pour pouvoir
s'y préparer sérieusement le conseil du
front du salut national semble sur le
point de leur donner satisfaction
il l'a déjà fait pour la revendication
étudiante de report des examens demain
une manifestation aura tout de même lieu
à bucarest une large part de la jeunesse
persiste à trouver certains nombres de
la nouvelle direction trop compromis
avec le régime ceausescu
depuis ce matin à pantin aux portes de
paris il existe une rue timisoara
l'intention de cette municipalité
communiste de seine-saint-denis est très
clair ne pas confondre ceausescu et pcs
pour autant le maire de pantin jacques
isabelle réclame avec les contestataires
du pcf le départ de georges marchais sur
l'hommage rendu ce matin à la roumanie
reportage de dominique maillot il ya des
trains de l'histoire qu'il faut savoir
prendre en marche
jacques isabelle mère depuis 13 ans de
pantin un des fiefs du pc dans la
banlieue parisienne a décidé de donner
le nom de timisoara à une des rues de sa
ville en souvenir des victimes roumaine
de la securitate jeu en signe de
solidarité avec le peuple roumain sur
nos deux aspects renforcement la cdt
matériel et surtout affirmations de la
solidarité politique
mouvement démocratique après marcelin
berthelot maire de saint-denis autres
bastions traditionnels du pc jacques
isabey rejoint ainsi le nombre croissant
d'élus communistes qui se démarque de
plus en plus de georges marchais jeunes
approcherait pas les crimes commis en
roumanie avec l'activité du parti
communiste français n'y avait causé
aucun communiste français je t'ai je
crois c'est que le parti communiste
obtenu 22% des suffrages ya dix ans il
en a moins de 7% aujourd'hui sachant
souffre terriblement je pense
qu'effectivement il ya des
responsabilités qui sont à établir mais
cette initiative avait sur place des
détracteurs vitupérant des militants du
front national étaient venus en nombre
pour perturber la cérémonie et dénoncer
ce qu'ils considèrent comme une
récupération et on a pu ainsi assister à
des échanges de slogans allant de
communistes assassin à l'open
tortionnaires mais la sagesse a
finalement prévalu et leur ont été
évités de justesse
voilà ce que nous pouvions dire ce soir
à propos de la roumanie et vous l'avez
compris donc de bucarest jusqu'à pantin
ces derniers jours c'est à propos d'
anis naccache et du terrorisme
proche-orientale que l'on a évoqué la
grâce présidentielle et bien ce soir
c'est une toute autre affaire qui nous
rappellent fort à propos que ce droit de
grâce existe
françois mitterrand vient de l'exercer
au bénéfice d'un certain yves ponthieu
ponthieu condamné à 20 ans de réclusion
criminelle pour le viol et le meurtre
d'une infirmière
alors pour mieux comprendre ce qui a pu
motiver cette grâce présidentielle
rappel des faits à like je prends pas je
suis comme dans un sur un nuage
je commence à peine à réaliser que je
suis avec l'humain en dehors de ces
quatre murs qui est qui s'appelle la
prison mais ce qui ne veut pas dire que
le
ma condamnation est fini non elle existe
encore faudra encore se battre pour
obtenir cette révision de procès
justement quelles sont vos intentions
aujourd'hui mais j'ai intention c'est de
continuer le combat pour obtenir
première manche
la révision de son procès et puis
l'acquittement
vous priez toujours votre innocence je
crée mon innocence
alors voilà c'était la déclaration d'isf
ponthieu tout aussitôt qu'il soit sorti
de la prison de loos les lille donc
aussitôt connue la grâce présidentielle
il contient donc réagissez au micro de
nos confrères de fr3 lille tout à
l'heure mais nous allons à présent avec
alain eck revivre l'époque des faits
1980 c'était dans le département de
l'ain a un petit problème je crois pour
nous allons l'avoir tout premier mystère
dans la nuit du 16 au 17 juillet 1981
les gendarmes de hauteville lompnès
reçoivent un appel anonyme
le corps d'une femme se trouve au col de
la perche
quand ils s'y rendent il ne trouve
personne c'est après un second appel le
18 juillet que les gendarmes trouvent au
lieu indiqué le corps de monique
soubeyrand une infirmière du centre
hospitalier second mystère auprès du
corps en évidence de livres érotiques
le libraire de longuenesse affirme les
avoir vendues à un collègue de monique
soubeyrand yves ponthieu mais d'une part
l'un des deux livres disparaît au cours
de l' enquête et d'autre part le
témoignage d'un gendarme présent au
moment de l'achat des livres n'apparaît
qu'au cours d'une seconde phase de cette
enquête puis disparaît troisième mystère
au cours d'une contre-enquête et faire 3
mettra en évidence que le fournisseur du
libraire la dral diffusion rhône-alpes
du livre ne lui a jamais vendu ses
ouvrages
quand le ministère de la justice or
donnera une nouvelle instruction pour
répondre à une demande de révision du
procès il la confiera à la même
gendarmerie qui n'interroge ra jamais
les responsables de l'ade râle gracié
yves ponthieu est aujourd'hui libre il
il reste encore à être réhabilité pas
donc pour cette affaire il fonctionne
gracié aujourd'hui par le président de
la république qu'il contient qui avaient
été condamnées en 83 à 20 ans de
réclusion pour le meurtre d'une
infirmière à présent ce qu'il faut
encore savoir de l'actualité aujourd'hui
à l'étranger les commentaires sont dans
de réelles
opération délicate autour du pétrolier
dernier un cargo 5 les techniciens sont
en effet en train d'étudier la meilleure
façon de transvaser les quelques 200000
tonnes de pétrole brut qu'il contient
toujours dans ses entrailles le navire
remorqué actuellement vers le sud du
globe
après avoir été déclarée bateau non
grata par l'espagne le portugal le maroc
et le sénégal
agitation toujours en bulgarie où
l'homme fort pétards mladenov a dû
monter en première ligne pour tenter de
calmer les nationalistes qui perturbe le
pays
grève des manifestations se succèdent
dans la capitale sofia et dans plusieurs
régions à tel point que la situation est
qualifiée d'alarmante par les
responsables bulgares
l'allemagne doivent réduire de 50% leurs
forces de défenses et l'étonnante
proposition aujourd'hui du parti
communiste est-allemand proposition
destinée à libérer des fonds afin de
restructurer l'économie de rda et
surtout pour permettre à cette dernière
de sortir du marasme
enfin aux etats-unis c'est une secte
dissidente des mormons qui se trouve sur
la sellette après la découverte de
quatre cadavres que les membres de la
secte aurait assassiné horriblement
mutilé les corps des victimes parmi
lesquels trois enfants aurait succombé à
ce que c'est que cette secte du middle
west américain intitule un sacrifice
humain course à la voile en solitaire
autour du monde il y a huit jours entre
noël et nouvel an philippe poupon avait
rappelé vous frôler la catastrophe qu'il
avait attendu de l'aide durant plusieurs
heures sur le flotteur de son catamaran
chavirait à près de 2000 km des côtes
d'afrique du sud et bien aujourd'hui
tout va bien poupon a mis pied à terre
et bien sûr laurent cela 3 la chaîne de
la mer était la poupe ont mis hors
course du globe challenge est arrivé
sans encombre ce matin au cap en afrique
du sud
pris en remorque par un bateau de
sauvetage il avoue quand même avoir été
très effrayé commentaires de jean
philippe bien philippe poupon enfin
souriant aujourd'hui à son arrivée au
cap
une foule d'admirateurs l'attendait sur
le quai mais le souvenir des terribles
vague des 40e rugissants est encore très
vivaces ou qu'on n'avait pas réussi à
redresser son monocoque fleury michon
sans doute trop peu lester pour sa
surface de voilure
ça m'est jamais arrivé en monocoque
on joue du gros mauvais temps quand même
e
la bateau ben non ils voulaient pas
revenir alors
dans les premières minutes on se dit
qu'il va revenir on attend une vague en
attend d'eux
mer se calme que le vent se calme un
petit peu dans l'espace alors rapidement
il ya quand même des choses à faire il
ya des débats la stab ine
pendant 18 heures seul au milieu de
l'océan en poupe on attendra l'arrivée
de son compatriote loïck peyron
si elle a bien sûr et comporter cette
aide extérieure interdite par le
règlement est à synonyme d'abandon fait
sorti j'ai vu j'ai vu loïc et son bateau
et bon ben évidemment j'étais content et
puis après ça s'est passé rapidement la
manoeuvre on l'a fait rapidement et la
première ville
tentative n'a pas marché
ensuite j'étais série dark et le
le mât d'artimon qui a facilité le
le redressement du bateau poupon
deuxième derrière titouan lamazou au
moment de l'avarice n'avait plus qu'une
solution rejoindre l'afrique du sud pour
réparer et malgré tous ces ennuis
il se dit prêt à repartir pour la
prochaine édition du globe challenge ce
qu'il vous faut retenir encore de
l'actualité en france grâce aux 25
stations régionales de la 3 commentaires
sophie guyot
deux personnes arrêtées dans un café de
vésinne près de montargis de la
conséquence immédiate de la saisie de
drogue opéré jeudi dernier à péronne
dans la somme
22 kilos d'héroïne avaient été
découverts sous un faux plancher dans un
camion en provenance de turquie
les deux hommes arrêtés étaient les
destinataires de cette cargaison
ils pourraient bien être les
organisateurs d'un véritable réseau turc
à faire cela johnson enquête
rebondissent cna jones était cette jeune
touriste anglaise disparue en août
dernier près de compiègne
son meurtrier présumé frédéric blank
avaient été arrêtés quelques temps après
et avait fait des aveux aujourd'hui dans
le journal le parisien
son frère affirme frédéric n'est pas
coupable il aurait seulement été témoin
d'humeur et se sentaient accusé des
faits par peur du véritable meurtrier à
cagnes le rpr et l'udf se présenterons
finalement unis à l'élection municipale
du 28 janvier prochain un accord de
principe est intervenu ce matin pour la
constitution d'une liste commune en mars
dernier michel mouillot candidat udf
avait été élu face au maire sortant rpr
anne marie dupuis mais l'élection avait
été annulée en raison de la violence des
propos durant la campagne électorale
autre compétition hippique cela les
résultats du tiercé quarté + disputée
aujourd'hui à vincennes il fallait jouer
le 4 le vin et le 6 dans l'ordre on se
sent 21 francs et 153 francs dans le
désordre et puylaurens le quarté + pour
le quarté + vous ajoutez le 10 86 dicks
et vous gagnez 14500 44 30 dans l'ordre
et 1131 francs dans le désordre
voilà voilà cette édition du 19 ans est
sur le point de se terminer dans un
instant la météo complète de michel tour
est ce soir sur la chaîne sommes
dynamiques comme d'habitude les
divertissant pour les jeunes à 20h35
l'information 21h55 soir 3 présenté par
nagui gilbert 22h20 le divan d'henri
chapier sur lequel s'allonge ce soir
jeanne bourin une grande dame jeanne
bourin donc sur le divan d'henri chapier
et merci bonsoir bon dimanche excellent
week-end à tout savoir